the war in ukraine reaches its hundredth
day if you can believe it we thought it
was important to take stock of where we
are
christopher caldwell a contributing
editor at the claremont review of books
wrote a stunning guest essay in the new
york times arguing that the conflict is
spiraling out of control and how u.s
policy making has contributed to that he
writes even if we don't accept mr
putin's claim that america's arming of
ukraine is the reason the war happened
in the first place it is certainly the
reason the war has taken the kinetic
explosive deadly form it has
our role in this is not passive or
incidental we've given ukrainians caused
to believe they can prevail in a war of
escalation
that naturally may create among american
policy makers a sense of moral and
political obligation to stay the course
to escalate the conflict to match any
excess
well given that level-headed warning
this headline in the hill caught our eye
36 experts agree stay the course
in ukraine
now the signatures narrowly uh naturally
include a panoply of msnbc and cnn green
room fixtures but we couldn't help but
get the sense that we've heard this
language before we're doing the right
thing and we must stay the course
my message today
uh to those in iraq is we'll stay the
course
so are there many billions in weaponry
that we're sending to ukraine is it
really about ensuring a victory for
ukraine or is it just needlessly
extending the bloodshed as part of some
elite vanity project from a foreign
policy establishment that's been wrong
on most everything during the last two
decades
joining me now is glenn greenwald
co-founder of the intercept and author
of securing democracy
glenn how many times have we heard
this stay the course of victories around
the corner we got him on the run let's
surge and do
you know pick your pick your city or
town
are you surprised by this at this point
you know every time i've been on your
show to talk about this war from the
start the theme has always been the one
question
that's most important happens to be the
one never being asked which is in what
way does this war
serve the interests of the american
people it doesn't obviously it serves
the interest of a tiny sliver of people
in washington weapons manufacturers
people in the security state who get
money and power from these sorts of
things and right at the moment when
their market for these weapons
disappeared when the u.s finally got out
of iraq and afghanistan low and behold
there's this new market in ukraine and i
think the op-ed
really reflects the fact of how
suppressed the debate has been because
it points to things like we've been in
ukraine since 2014 we've been arming
them since at least 2017 or 2018 with
heavy weaponry making very provocative
gestures toward russia right on the
other side of the border and there's
been an absence of any attempt to
resolve the word diplomatically which is
what you would be doing trying to solve
it diplomatically if you actually cared
about the ukrainians the biden
administration instead has been
escalating the war seemingly
deliberately which is what you would do
if you don't care about ukrainians but
instead care about weapons manufacturers
and the power of the u.s security state
joe biden glenn uh gave a it's basically
just a non-answer
on what he he believes needs to happen
next watch
mr president does ukraine have to see
territory to achieve some peace
it's their territory i'm not going to
tell them
what they should and shouldn't do
but it appears to me that at some point
along the line there's a
settlement here what that entails i
don't know but in the meantime we're
going to continue to put
the the
ukrainians in a position where they can
defend themselves
glenn germany and france have already
just a few days ago
urged russia to go back to the
negotiating table they want this over
clearly it's killing their economy uh
economies and biden's still meandering
down this road of we're gonna you know
we're gonna keep sending more weapons
there what's your response to this
so i think there's been a clear
narrative shift in how the media has
been describing this war over the last
couple of weeks that's quite notable for
the first three months the media has
barely acknowledged russian advances at
all if you were listening to them you
would think the ukrainians have
vanquished this much more powerful
russian military many times the experts
said they were days away from a
full-scale military collapse and now the
media is acknowledging that they have
essentially consolidated control over
large portions of eastern ukraine which
is what putin said from the beginning
was his goal
so in order to actually expel the
russians from ukrainian territory and go
back to the pre-invasion borders you
would need a commitment over many years
that would be extremely dangerous and
very expensive we can't win a war on the
other side of the world without a
sacrifice well beyond what americans are
or should be willing to endure glenn you
called this from the beginning and
sadly you were right but we really
appreciate your perspective tonight
thank you thank you or good to be with
you